kannst du dich erinnern
kannst du dich an die harten Kämpfer so
da kommen wir bald die Tränen wenn ich
mit dir hier lang gehe nee die
Frankfurter Festhalle der Ort an dem er
Geschichte geschrieben hat
Weltmeister Europameister fünfmal
Deutschlands Boxer des Jahres Rene
Weller
deine Kämpfe und deine Seele
das ist René Weller heute der 68-Jährige
leidet seit 2014 an Demenz an seine
größten Erfolge kann er sich kaum mehr
erinnern und die haben Substanz ist von
Ohren gegangen und wenn wir uns jetzt
diese Veränderung anschauen dann geht es
leider mit dem auch einher dass wir eine
deutliche Leistungseinschränkung haben
auch vor allem in der Merkfähigkeit in
Kurzzeitgedächtnis immer an seiner Seite
seine Gattin Maria
aufopferungsvoll kämpft sie um ihn 24
Stunden am Tag 7 Tage die Woche alles
für ihren René wie viel Jahre würden sie
geben bis es eben wissen sie auch nicht
wir können keine zeitprognose wirklich
geben das kann man nicht genau sagen und
ich glaube es ist auch wichtig dass man
dort jetzt nicht in langen in langen
Zeit Abständen denkt sondern da wie
wichtig ist es ja auch jeden einzelnen
Tag jede einzelne Nacht sozusagen
einfach miteinander zu machen man kann
schon durchaus auch mal das ein oder
andere bisschen vorher bleiben
vielleicht aber
ganz langen Abständen wird man nicht
wird man nicht planen können maria ist
verzweifelt Rene hat Pflegestufe 4 kann
nicht mehr alleine essen duschen oder
auf die Toilette gehen Geld für einen so
nötigen Pflegeheimplatz haben sie nicht
doch die beiden geben nicht auf sie
hoffen noch immer auf den Lucky Punch im
härtesten Kampf im Leben von René Weller
[Musik]